Facebook's global head of safety insists
the social network is safe most of the
time antigone Davis told Sky News that
Facebook finds one area especially
challenging when you're talking about
hate speech it can require a good deal
of context in in which you need to
understand the term that someone has
used or how they're using it and it's
not why hate speech is an area where you
really need human involvement I think
that is an area where we need more human
involvement Facebook's own figures
showed the extent of its difficulty in
the first three months of 2018 its
algorithms found ninety-nine point seven
percent of spam before it was flagged by
users 99.5 percent of terrorist
propaganda and only 38 percent of hate
speech that figure doesn't include the
many posts never picked up by Facebook's
detection systems yet found easily with
a quick search I've very quickly found
this item you'll see it's linking to a
YouTube video about Jewish ritual murder
there's a post here very clearly
anti-semitic how can that be on Facebook
especially given this has been such a
big issue well I think this goes exactly
back to what you were asking us before
asking before in terms of hate speech
there's a lot of context if this is
reported to us it violates our policies
were removing it if we're if we are able
to with our technologies before and we
hope to prevent that kind of content in
the first place today Facebook is for
politics as much as friends with
activists such as the organizers of the
women's March rallying first on the
social network new research commissioned
by Facebook shows how that activity and
the way it opens up people to abuse is
changing public life some people thought
that was a good thing that actually was
good that we were becoming a bit more
you know thick-skinned others really
didn't and they found the whole
experience very very difficult and
actually in some cases they would either
fold and give up or they would double
down and become very single-minded very
angry very wise Ellis about their their
cause actually I don't think either of
those things are particularly where we
want to be on social action with the
drumbeat of regulation growing ever
louder
it says Facebook is committed to
governing responsibly will we make
mistakes absolutely we're going to make
mistakes are we always aiming to get it
right and to do better absolutely
but at Facebook's scale we're a small
slip can cause catastrophe even its best
may not be good enough run a month off
Sky News